let's say that I have the unit vector U
and in the horizontal direction for
every 1/3 it goes it goes square root of
8 over 3 in the vertical direction and
we can verify that this is indeed a unit
vector the magnitude of our vector U is
going to be equal to the square root of
the sum of these of the squares of the
components and this once again just come
straight out of the Pythagorean theorem
so it's going to be equal to the square
root of 1 3 squared 1 3 squared plus
square root of 8 over 3 squared plus
square root of 8 over 3 squared and
what's that going to be well that's
going to be equal to the square root of
1 over 9 plus 8 over 9 plus 8 over 9
which is equal to I think you see this
coming
square root of 9 over 9 which is equal
to 1 so this is indeed a unit vector now
let's say someone says well I like this
direction but I don't want the magnitude
to just be 1 I want to find some vector
V I want to find some vector V that has
the same direction so has same direction
as you same direction as you but has a
magnitude of 11 so we want the vector V
to have a magnitude of 11 so how could I
define vector V well one way to think
about is if we just scale each of the
components of U up by 11 then we will
have gone in the same direction but now
we will have a magnitude 11 times as big
and if we start with the magnitude of 1
will now have a magnitude of 11 so we
could say that vector V is could be 11 x
times 1/3 comma square root of 8 over 3
and so what is this going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to 11 over 3
11 over 3 comma 11 square roots of 8 11
square roots of eight square roots of
eight over three and I encourage you if
you don't believe me try it and it I
guess on one level it should make sense
that when you multiply a vector times
the scalar right like this it just
scales it it just scales it in that
direction by this factor so if your
magnitude was one your magnitude will
now be eleven in that direction but if
you want you could you could actually
verify mathematically that the magnitude
here if you were to calculate it is
going to be eleven instead of one as in
the case of unit vector you